ha so I was just cleaning my shirt roll
the clip
some TTT we'll have to do okay let's try
and land on each other's faces
you know the trusting game when you when
you jump backwards and you land on their
faces so that in like a a hence I want
to build hey what is up okay
catch me who's a minx you catch me I
said I trust ya I can't lie with a Ken
right now dude catch me [ __ ] again yeah
okay yes minx is clear we should go find
somebody okay we're at the stairs right
okay what color is on the floor that
leads to you a green and red green red
so there'd be this one alright wait your
kids
um wait one second okay ready
I can't yeah can this little got you
mistress
there's two more green right here Oh
valid ml [ __ ] where you guys where
cry had the room when the chainsaw
oh it's like a period when it wakes are
slammed mining Ken's corpses together
yeah uh down here how can you forget a
special moment like yeah looks right
uncool don't never I will never forget
that moment
okay I'll catch you just like ash putt
catches Oh digging my it bounced off
your head alright alright cry can I
trust you catch me catch me catch me cry
cats are you textin right catch me Ken
good ok it's this like what what ha ha
no no that [ __ ] don't shoot
it was Ted no what don't shoot what I
really do it again
it's cinnamon toast murder GH raise you
think looking aft gun me ma is that
three times in a row you the tears
people want to go off I guess it didn't
said it oh you have to set it and then
he got a press e on it to arm it I
didn't arm dit but I guess I'll soon
that's why I wanted to come gotta be in
like the general region
okay don't know okay can you can you
catch me Ken to see us again
wait let's cry dude you never can I
trust Ken okay can I trust you huh who
are you
who's gonna catch Nick catch me okay
okay thank you I catch you going on
peers you catch him so you're in a
relationship it's only fair okay here we
go
you can totally trust me I totally catch
you you catch me I think it's up to
kradic catch next you know what I think
it's mix she's been way too quiet
mmm that's the first thing crusted there
all right okay okay she okay huh oh
hello
what's this c4 here yeah what's that
buddy huh
explain that chicken chicken Yoda Shane
it's a yeah explain it my seconds the
[ __ ] I do you are me you got a proceed
on it hit neonate it brings up a bar and
everything all right god damn it
ha ha dos being cold here oh yeah I got
him we're like what let's keep catching
each other
geez Huck uh like that sure is taking
his time long was it there you like just
put it down yeah and I wasn't a great oh
I thought you were the best writer ever
peace Oh your jaw are you just too sweet
yeah because you've been easy for us to
be here I mean I stopped shooting each
other guys stop shooting each other stop
[ __ ] shooting it it's like a spring
like a it's like you sort of like
spraying um my eyes on us the commas
down with thanks Mike stop that's it
stop stop stop
What's Wrong bud whoa I got a Dean it
found out to do use her yourself
I got a discombobulated er all right all
right
I'm innocent gasps I'm innocent we're
catching - hey I'm talking this kill
Felix that's raised you last week's
that's suspicious whoa whoa whoa what is
that what is that what is that what I
saw something what is that what is that
oh I don't know Oh smart good night I'm
throwing in the middle hair wait uh
where uh where huh why Ken what what's
going on whose shoes I'll disarm the
Seaboard these combined will stop
discombobulating [ __ ] hi buddy
whenever you I'm really good
you want to go out for coffee no sorry
kid well you know right you don't like
happy no [ __ ] you
oh well don't mind if I do oh Oh Oh your
guy sold it
oh thank you getting together I'm sorry
damn I wish legacies that came with your
outline boy the sequence when you got it
crazy cans like I can be such a jokester
look what I'm doing
Oh Kenny all right what do you do Kenny
cry can't cry what're you doing I'm
fingers not on YouTube okay
hey Dad I thought I did also mildly yeah
disarmed it it means you were like let's
a kill Butte so I was like [ __ ] this is
my moment
yeah like lost than this brewski dang it
I want to get out we smoked this place
up we can't get out oh it's the doors
closed [ __ ]
well I think minks planted the ban the
BAM yeah I did not I did not [ __ ] the
pot the BAM if there's a bomb we can
hear it tick what she hasn't armed it
yet now so much are they that someone
shot me
oh yeah you left out awesome a shooting
house no I know I leave that what dog no
you're shooting the wrong guy you shoot
another one guy see I was in the wrong
guy
yeah it was wrong yeah uh uh happened
Kevin it makes it over yeah yeah it
you're you new trailer voice trainer boy
he's got to work on it
yep don't you guys talking about are you
really buying this now looking for him
oh there's gonna be an intersection
coming up oh I see a sue Isis target
will be he's in the Stargate mm-hmm okay
you guys get your niche gotcha
can I come too I'm Ellie oh ah looks
like got you to kill PewDiePie before a
wins bro do I love you say man there's
been so much homoerotic material and
this recording old haters damn there has
went to disapproval like everyone up
lately eNOS everyone's wants penis it
should be a sound
what are you doing minx I can't mood for
some reason
Hector innate underneath you
it another need because I don't like her
in people how about Reggie
I won't you got an say sir why do you do
this when you shoot at me
I think I shoot you shooting I assure
you cry cry cry cry I only oh look
that's a gather finally apparently the
knife isn't what it comes my god can you
get minx alrighty right click one time I
can show you the world Jesus Christ
yeah I can show you the world or how to
twerk Oh chef anyway would you wear or
how to [ __ ] twerk twerk work it out
alright let's play right around okay
let's make my value out of this bout
five vital follow Oh elevator elevator
doc I heard someone screaming agony oh
[ __ ] laughing you crushed me you're a
terrorist
I think nothing gained has it started
yet so that probably means he's gonna be
the terrace Oh
oh wow
you just left an elevator for you keep
in stop it [ __ ] okay gasps okay
let's look at a cranberry crummers
gerber jack OOP doesn't get go man -
sorry I'm one likes potage Oh Oh
somebody hit the elevators a week in
there oh my overnight movie he's gonna
blow us down since link opens okay
that's spot-on
oh it is the elevator okay oh I don't
even know where it is hey make it better
that's all just use cry boss what is
your profession crowbar terror it's
innocent
yes innocent all right can we meet you
up LSR crime we'll meet you up at the
Stargate
what's up about this we won't kill you
if you walk through the Stargate
yourself how about that for you
yesterday
all right we'll give you a chance come
on come to the Stargate we'll wait for
you I'm gonna see how much you my buddy
I can put through the Stargate without
like getting in trouble and that's that
idea
I don't none of the way man up max thank
my left restaurant what happened see huh
what happened that was the worst Lester
Tiffany that was the worst lie throw is
it was that the really last round no I
mean this it showed that he was a
traitor even yeah that's it yeah it's
probably how it works yeah that's pretty
funny it's not funny it was pretty funny
no it's not how did you guys write more
fun of us we I mean the second time
right well meet when you lost someone
shot me okay I was busy getting sucked
into the Stargate it's probably [ __ ]
Ken oh you should go in there and have a
kid the imputes are flying with the
Stargate yeah you see you slip through
outside hey hey can i hey
okay let's play this list mates a good
last round yeah yeah okay I [ __ ] hear
it - no it's Howie
Rushton
did it really get that when you walked
it I didn't kill you the elevator how I
swear the elevator crushed him really
yes I am I'm underneath the elevator
again - okay see you seem reputable you
know it says this is it on your name you
are my pride in here to make this more
entertaining uh mixes in I commend well
I'm not thirsty for today yeah it's
[ __ ] legs
all right for Sylvain but let's go to
the next one that flows bad this floor
has smoke box all right well I got one
start off okay yes I [ __ ] told you
who is minx
yeah I said it in the beginning of the
game
I'm sorry occurs in the elevator oops
hope you enjoy the video live like if
you're dead so parents can buy me more
downtown anyway hey there's two damn
guys humping in the other Riverhead it
was a miniature through the game I get a
little shielding your back that's Zoey I
mean we would never have guys like that
eh don't worry about being gay what your
hair